big space exploration day sort of on the
program we interviewed Andy weir who
wrote the Martian and then we also have
really big news from the world of space
exploration because Elon Musk's company
SpaceX has launched their new rocket the
Falcon Heavy from Kennedy Space Center
in Florida and this is the most powerful
vehicle really since the space shuttle
system to be launched into the solar
system into orbit I don't know what to
call it the payload was sort of
satirical it was Elon Musk's own red
Tesla sports car with like a mannequin
or I guess we would call it more like a
crash-test dummy yeah in the driver's
seat of his test I would have taken it
you didn't have to send that I know yeah
it's like I would I would have driven
that around the maximum payload of this
rocket is 64 tons which is similar to
five city buses the orbit is towards
Mars it's actually an orbit around the
Sun that's elliptical and it will go in
the direction of Mars at one point and
part of this launch one of the really
big things about this launch was landing
the boost stages of the rocket the lower
segments back on earth which is
something that SpaceX has been trialing
for a while to happen successfully which
we're showing our television audience
one ended up missing its target and was
destroyed when it hit the water but two
out of three is not bad and this is just
a major accomplishment I mean the
implications of this a lot of times with
these types of endeavors the discoveries
that come as a result are not only
unplanned but sometimes unforeseen go
but some of the ideas as to the meaning
of this are number one this could lead
to launching bigger satellites that's
something that's currently limited by
the Rockets that we have you could
potentially launch a batch of satellites
in one go maybe for the global broadband
idea that Elon Musk and others have
proposed this also increases the
complexity and the amount of payload
that you could send to the surface of
Mars or even planets that are further
away further away when we are ready for
that I don't I don't even say if anymore
I say when we are ready for that you
could send even larger telescopes into
space but really the game-changer is
when you get the rocket back by being
able to land it you're
costs go way down and there's this false
notion that some people hold that when
you do a space launch the fuel is most
of the expense and it's not the fuel
sometimes as little as 2% or up to five
six percent of the total cost of
launching a rocket into space so when
you lose the rocket you're losing the
vast majority of the money and when
you're able to get the rocket back and
use it again in terms of cost it's just
a game-changer like imagine imagine
Airlines right where all of the airlines
are throwing out the planes after each
flight and all of a sudden one airline
goes hey you know what we figured out a
way where we can reuse the plane we can
land them it's a game-changer right and
that's exactly what this allows for here
so this is an excitement level that III
mean I don't I can't say for sure
exactly when we had this level of
excitement about space exploration but
this is really accelerating a new wave
of space exploration and you've got
these private public partnerships
involving Boeing and SpaceX with NASA
that it's very very exciting so we're
going to Mars probably 2030s Pat's going
yeah I'm going specifically are you
taking SpaceX are you taking NASA or
you're taking Boeing I'm an
all-of-the-above I mean these are all
companies that have been hugely
innovative I don't think that again
because and and speaking of which now
seemed to Levin the Black Swan talks
about this as well because the benefits
of this type of work are often unknown
we have unknown unknowns we're going to
learn things we don't yet know we're
going to learn from this why am i go i
want SpaceX to do it instead of NASA
right I mean now of course we should all
be working on this stuff it's very very
interesting and beneficial and who knows
what we're going to get from it we're
human beings it's in our nature to
explore there you go and there's not
much left on the planet for us to
explore we got to go into outer space
now Pat Forde blog david pakman.com
that's an excerpt you just heard from
that from producer Pat Forde yes
exciting stuff and I know there's people
in the audience who will tell me David
we're never going to Mars and those are
the same people who said there were
never there would never be self-driving
cars the video you just watched was made
possible by soup
or from you please go to patreon.com
slash david pakman show you can make a
pledge of as little as one dollar per
month and every dollar helps to support
the work that we're doing particularly
in light of the YouTube ad boycott which
has been really bad